women will play the victims when they
started it like you can't hit a guy and
not expect to get hit back
that's
that's interesting I think we should
teach the women not to hit someone
stronger than them and they'll say like
men are responsible for all the [__]
you know but I really think it's on the
horse for being [__] I recently
decided that women shouldn't vote
the decided women shouldn't vote yeah
that's a new opinion why is that okay
I'll take one for the team yeah okay you
should have the same opinions you should
be voting for the same person as your
husband why it's like I don't know you
want to be in a house where you're
arguing about politics yes yeah I want
someone who thinks differently to me you
had a guy called Nick Fuentes oh yeah
yeah Nick I did not find Nick to be
racist my staff actually did not find
him to be racist you just did say I am a
bit racist even enough and in fact in
your apology you said that he said
racist things well I'm a bit confused
about is
you did a whole apology but it sounds
like you're not asking me about this
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantin kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People as you know what we do on
trigonometry is talk to people with a
variety of different views our guests
are often outspoken or controversial but
no matter who we're talking to we always
approach our interviews in good faith
that means we let our guests speak don't
misrepresent them and challenge them
respectfully if we disagree a couple of
days ago we interviewed a YouTuber
called just pearly things now in between
booking her to come on the show several
weeks ago and actually doing the
interview on Thursday she hosted a
well-known white supremacist openly
racist Holocaust denier called Nick
Fuentes on her show understandably that
generated a lot of pushback and she
deleted the interview and issued a
lengthy apology
given that we were happy to go ahead
with the interview
and we obviously had to bring up the
situation it's never Our intention to
make our guests look bad but we also
have a duty to ask these questions and
to challenge people when what they're
saying doesn't make sense to us when we
asked about the apology let's just say
things got very awkward very quickly
what you're about to watch is the full
unedited interview we haven't cut or
added anything so that as always you the
viewer can make up your own mind enjoy
our brilliant guest today is a fellow
YouTuber who started her show a year ago
and is now on over a million subscribers
Pearl uh Davis aka just pearly things
welcome to trigonometry thank you for
having me oh it's awesome thanks so much
for coming it's great to have you on as
I just picked you up you're you've
absolutely smashed it uh before we get
into all of that uh tell everybody who
are you how are you where you are what's
been the journey through life that leads
you to be sitting here talking to us so
my name is Pearl I'm a YouTuber
um I'm from Chicago I live in London I
do a YouTube show here
that was quick yeah how did you decide
to start it how did you have the idea I
just you could tell everybody what the
show is because a lot of people wouldn't
have seen it oh yeah all that stuff I'm
sorry that's fine
um so we talk about a lot of men's
issues so I feel like
most media today is Catered towards
women pandering towards women we don't
do that on my channel
you don't Pander to women no no we're
not about that and it happened to men uh
not panda look it I just say I say
things that are true okay I say things
that that are like basic to me right but
like what
you know you shouldn't get super fat
after you get married just because you
got a ring
like that's that's basic women in the
1950s knew that but today
I'm a bully I'm the meanest person ever
blah blah so so yeah that's what I do is
we talk about relationships on my show
um and so we bring in men and women
women to talk about different like
relationship topics and then we go back
and forth yeah and then I'm also I also
work a lot with um
um the court system here I'm doing a
documentary on men getting custody of
their kids interesting yeah and but one
of the things you did with your show and
I don't know if you were one of the
first ones but it's definitely a format
that's really skyrocketed the icon
opened my Twitter now without you know
eight people sitting around the table
having some discussion often they don't
know what they're talking about but it's
a format of bringing kind of random
people together partly random very
random very random very random yeah and
you also have famous people and we'll
talk about that as well but that did you
come up with that was something was that
something that you saw other people
doing like no um I would say fresh and
fit in Miami
um we're probably the first ones to do
that so I went on their show and what I
liked about London is it was one of the
most like diverse places I've ever lived
so I just thought it'd be cool to bring
everyone in a room and talk about
something that we all have in common
which is relationships that's very
interesting and so but why do you pick
the subjects that you do why are you
drawn to the subjects that you discuss
because they are controversial they
can't get you into hot water
Etc
um I just I follow what interests me and
I just thought those subjects were
interesting it wasn't a lot of people
think it's like a lot more drawn out
every week I'm just like oh that's an
interesting topic and we go for it
um I would say it's a mix of
relationships sometimes we add in some
conservative stuff but it's like mostly
about relationships and and why why does
that interest you both in particular do
you feel the relationships you're in
crisis now or we've done value
relationships or we look at
relationships men aren't allowed to have
standards in society and that's just
like the one thing I noticed like
whenever men
say that they want something in a
relationship like women always shame
them for it and I just thought it was so
interesting how we never like talk about
the men's point of view so when I first
started I I started like introducing my
friends to like certain types of content
so I would be like well have you ever
thought about this this way or ever
thought about that that way and I don't
know that's kind of how it started right
so a men are ashamed for having
standards what do you mean by that let's
just unpick that a little bit okay so
what do we have we have fat shaming if a
guy says I want a girl in shape oh he's
fat shaming oh if a guy says I don't
want the town [__] you know
then he's slut-shaming you know if he
says I don't want to like it's like
anytime a guy demands something out of a
relationship or he's labeled as
controlling and I just got oh my gosh I
got so tired in the past year I got so
tired because I just feel like I would
we would talk about like basic things
and the men would say basic things that
they wanted and like they would just
continue to be shamed for it and it's
just like one of those things once you
see it you can't unsee it so what what
are the basic things and and look a lot
of people who said you use let's put it
fruity language as they would say in the
1950s in England like the town hall oh
yeah okay
you should have said the city hall the
city hall yeah but so what do you mean
by that
what does that mean because sleeping
okay I met one girl
[Laughter]
she told me this was off camera she
didn't tell me this on camera
girl because we we had a pro-life show
girls had seven abortions
wow seven
she's like 28. it's like madness madness
like you can't tell me that's not
Madness right and so we're just in this
world where it's like girls are doing
this crazy crazy stuff
and if anyone has anything to say about
it we're the bad guys it's just like
don't put me in that group like well
that makes a lot of sense because I
think a lot of people including a lot of
women would be like you've had seven
abortions I mean even if you're
pro-choice you'd sort of not be on board
with that most people you would be
surprised you'd be surprised well you
think you think a lot of people are on
board with that maybe know I'm bored but
like legally oh yeah yeah here it's free
yeah yeah so
um yeah and do you think that these
particular women don't take
responsibility for their actions do you
think it's Society why would it's like
we live in a world where women are
bailed out of every single bad decision
we make if we want to sleep around
there's birth control if birth control
doesn't work there's abortion if if um
the girl does get pregnant and wants to
keep it she can put the dude on child
support and not let him see the kids
like what a guy gets six days a month
maybe if he's lucky
um on top of that if that doesn't go
well you know they can
give it up for adoption it's like women
are always bailed out of every bad
decision we make I heard here they give
you free housing if you're a single
mother what what incentive do we have to
make good decisions if we get free [__]
from the government for making bad
decisions
it's a good point but then surely isn't
the system at fault rather than the
individual pill
why
both I mean I think the system's at
fault for like allowing them to do that
but I mean I think your life is your own
fault yeah so if I you can't tell me a
girl had seven abortions that's not her
fault no no no
Francis always likes to blame the system
because he's an old school Lefty yeah
things about the city no I mean I would
say it's okay there's good people and
bad people but if you have a system that
allows bad people to do or bad people to
get away with the bad things that they
do
then of course
um the system's at fault too however
nah like your own life is your own fault
so I kind of see both sides when it
comes to that yeah and do you is are
these your politics that inform your
world view do you have a political
outlook on life
um I would say I'm like more
conservative but
like no it's just what I see in front of
me like to be honest you know I do
that's the sense I get from you you know
ideological you just go that stupid that
doesn't work etc right that's my take on
that's my sense of you yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay I'm sorry I thought you were
gonna say something else though uh no uh
and um how how have you found the
experience of like just bringing in
because you just literally do you just
grab people off the street oh gosh
oh that's hell uh recruiting as hell
um yeah basically a year ago I started
with like my teammates but I dunked on
them a little too hard so they stopped
coming on
I say that a guy that likes younger
women was a pedophile and I was just
like now I wasn't talking about underage
women okay I'd like declare don't clip
me don't do that
um but and I was just like
no like that's just natural that's what
men naturally want younger women yeah um
so yeah then they stopped coming on but
no we recruit through Instagram mostly
and so you get a bunch of random people
yes who want to come on the show yes to
discuss these things yes and you clearly
you know as you said you were dunking on
your own teammates too hard so they've
Left Right some of them came back they
did come back
and how how does that go because we do I
mean certainly from our perspective
living a society where as you say people
are uh very uncomfortable with certain
things that we all know are true being
said out loud in the public I how how
does that go when you get a bunch of
random people and you start dropping
your truth bombs
um sometimes well sometimes not well I
bet I've had a lot of girls come back
and say they changed their opinions
after coming on my show actually that
they see the world in a completely
different way but I would say the
majority hate me yeah not that come on
the show but like I don't know but
that's interesting so you've had people
who've changed their opinions can you
give a couple of examples of that I had
one friend that stopped being friends
with me last year because I had a post
about something that pissed her off
and um she literally said she stopped
being my friend wouldn't talk to me
whatever she came back three months
later and said you were right
and I was a crazy feminist and I
realized I was wrong and what was the
post
um modern women want to be victims
interesting so let's say so let's
explore let's explore that why do you
think that though
because they play the victim and
everything
okay
but again let's give some examples like
what do you mean by that is it okay okay
so when I started doing the show Girls
would come forward and they would say
like
I was abused right okay and my first
response as like a person is I believe
them right and I and I think you know
you have empathy right but then you find
out that they they didn't press any
charges against the guy
so you're coming on a platform and
you're saying I was afraid to press
charges but you're not afraid to talk on
my show
and this has happened multiple times so
people know who her exes that watch the
show so she's publicly defaming this
man's character with no proof or
evidence
and so I just think a lot of times like
or or they wouldn't they wouldn't talk
about how
I would ask the question he hit you okay
did you hit him first and more often
than not they would hit first oh wow
yeah and they didn't talk about that
they would talk so that's what I met as
I was talking about how like women will
play the victims when they started it
like you can't hit a guy and not expect
to get hit back
that's that's interesting why do you say
that because look so from my own
background I was raised whatever
happened whatever you do you never lay
hands on a woman you just never do that
whatever happens you absolutely never do
yeah I mean I I think they tell man that
because they cater to women if you hit
someone expect to get hit back well hold
on Mitch like why is why is she exempt
from any responsibility like okay if you
go up to Dwayne The Rock Johnson and you
punch him in the face is anyone gonna
feel bad when you get hit back no and he
knocks your brains out like why do we
have that men don't have a cop-out for
that but if a woman hits a man who's
stronger than him there's always a
cop-out then she's the victim oh never
hit no offense but never never hit a
woman blah blah blah it's like no you
hit him first get out of here and now
we're having cases where men are dying
from women like in Florida where that
only fans model did you guys hear about
that there was an only fans model who um
killed her boyfriend
and
um like at first they thought it was
like a mutually abusive relationship now
CCTV TV footage
I don't know if it's called the same
thing there but elevator footage has
come out and um
like it's of her like literally beating
the [__] out of him
and like what she doesn't deserve to get
hit
I mean I the Equal Rights equal laughs
baby
I guess the counter argument to that is
if a woman hits me
uh it's not gonna do with the vast
majority of cases that much damage now
we had Veronica Hardy in the studio with
her husband Dan and Veronica's a UFC
fighter and Veronica would destroy me in
a matter of seconds but
the reality is I can hit harder than the
vast majority of women and cause more
damage yeah so then it's on the women to
not hit the man why would you hit
someone stronger than you
and this is what I mean like when we
look at Society there's always like a
bailout so even right there like you did
it and I think there's a lot of like
little things that we don't notice in
societies where it's like never hit a
woman why
why like why why does she sort of person
to teach your son however there are
exceptions so this is what I was gonna
ask you imagine you're walking down the
street with your girlfriend yeah and a
woman runs over and starts beating up
your girlfriend
yeah never hit a woman
yeah so to me
I would physically restrain her and I
would what if she started beating you up
well I was once if she had enough or a
stick or a [__] okay right okay then
in that case yeah well my whole point in
this is like there see right there
that's a bailout The Woman made a bad
decision and we put it on the men to
bail them out
yeah
um so it's like again if you go if we're
making it a strength argument right
we're talking about strength you hitting
Dwayne The Rock Johnson he can't hit you
back then
yeah but see it's a gender thing it's
like women are always seen as the victim
even if they started it and that was my
point like with that post is like these
women will will play the victim on my
show and this has happened so many like
so many times where a girl come forward
I was abused this happened this happened
then I start asking questions and this
is the thing like in society they act
like we can't ask any questions when a
woman says abuse says I I don't say the
r word on my grape whatever but then you
say did you press charges no well why
are you publicly defaming a man's
character because they people know who
you dated
so we've had a bunch of feminists on the
show and I can hear their voices in my
head right now yeah and here's what they
would say they would say look if you
look at the statistics a woman is much
more likely to be killed or grape or
whatever by her own partner so the
biggest threat to a woman is the person
that the man that she's living with
right women are way more likely to be
men are more likely to be victims of a
violent crime yeah who cares who's the
perpetrator yeah if men are more likely
to be victims because then they'll
always say oh well I can't walk home
alone at night I got attacked by a whale
because of that statement
um yeah I just think who cares who who
does it do you not think though that if
we live in a society where we have what
biologists call sexual dimorphism like
men are different to women physically
right men of bigger stronger Etc because
women are physically on average less
able to protect themselves we should
have some sort of extra care I'm not
saying you know never hit a woman
because I can envisage a situation where
in self-defense or whatever that that
may happen but we have to teach men to
be extra careful with the strength that
they have particularly when they're
dealing with women I think we should
teach the women not to
hit someone stronger than them like I
don't understand why do we put it on the
BET put it on the women don't hit like
you should teach the women don't hit
anyone if you don't expect to get hit
back I agree with that and I don't think
anyone should be able to press charges
on a guy if if she hit first she started
it yeah but what about if she hit first
and then it escalated and as a result of
that she was severely beaten that surely
should be able to press charges because
the level of violence is
disproportionate to the situation if you
hit the Dwayne The Rock Johnson first
and then he beat the [__] out of you
well it depends if you're given brain
damage I think you'd probably could
press charge yeah absolutely because
it'd be Grievous bodily harm because the
whole put though it's at least an
English law and there'll be somebody who
corrects me on this it's self-defense po
it's it's self-defense if you attack me
I'm allowed to defend myself but then it
comes a point where I'm no longer
defending myself and I become the
aggressor do you see yeah I see what
you're saying I just genuinely believe
that you should not hit someone and not
expect to get hit back I that that's my
opinion I mean there is there is a logic
and I and I just don't think you can
really play the victim if you hit first
like you hit first yeah well I mean it's
one thing if it's like you shouldn't hit
people right yeah but it's just
interesting how in society it's like see
you kind of like not just you it's like
very common we always like take the
responsibility off of the women and like
put it on the men somehow yeah
hey Francis do you want to protect your
privacy cool so I do now that I'm an
International Celebrity who's appeared
on hit shows like The Joe Rogan
Experience I have to protect myself from
vicious people looking to tear me down
on the Michael Jackson of the internet
not the celebrity I would have gone for
but trust is important when picking a
VPN I don't trust anyone after she left
me she took everything Francis remember
what your lawyer said good point you can
trust expressvpn because they don't sell
your data to advertisers they've even
created software called trusted server
that means they can't store any data at
all expressvpn uses lightweight a VPN
protocol that makes user speeds faster
than ever expressvpn is now blazingly
fast you can watch HD videos with zero
buffering thousands of pounds in legal
fees the great thing about expressvpn is
that you don't need any technical skills
to set up just like Francis fire up the
app and it's one button to connect One
Tap on a button was all it needed for my
entire life to disintegrate
loads of people are saying that
expressvpn is the best VPN there is
Business Insider The Verge and many
other Tech journals rate expressvpn as
the number one VPN in the world go on
Francis protect yourself with
expressvpn use or link
expressvpn.com trigger today and get an
extra three months free on a one-year
package that's
expressvpn.com trigger visit
expressvpn.com trigger to learn more she
took everything
while I think the way that you're
talking is quite blunt about it there is
some truth to what you're saying and
more broadly there's other areas where I
think that probably applies as well
right yeah just beyond the physical
stuff what like can you give us some
other examples of what you're talking
about
things that you talk to people on the
show about
um like one thing is that men shouldn't
sleep with so many women
and they'll say like men are responsible
for all the [__] you know but I really
think it's on the horse for being [__]
no I'm serious is it's like well they'll
be like well if the men weren't sleeping
around but it's like okay what percent
of men can sleep around right one out of
three men are sexless so but by this
logic like it's more on the women than
the men but it's like then they put it
on the small percentage of men that are
sleeping around does that make sense
yeah yeah it does make sense I don't
know if you've heard that argument or
not I haven't actually no yeah I've
never heard anyone blame the men for the
fact that women are doing a lot of
sleeping around that's really I hear it
all the time I always yeah they always
say like
um women
um like but the men are sleeping around
when we talk about like women being
[__] yeah
it's like but the man but the man said
but but but I also oh I think it's 100
the woman's fall if you get pregnant
yeah it's interesting why 100
um because we have 41 forms of birth
control
and um the what if birth control fails
condoms what if you someone could I know
someone who was using condoms and birth
control
[Music]
okay yeah but you're saying adoption I
mean I don't believe in abortion but
it's legal so then you you have 100
control over who's born as a woman um
there's always a risk of pregnancy you
know so it's it is is that really fair
to say that yes
but I guess because the man only has one
choice I guess you could do two
vasectomies condom no condom yeah right
where the woman has like 20 choices
abortion no abortion plan b or no plan B
41 forms of birth control or No 41 forms
of birth control
um what else is there adoption no
adoption
um child support no child support
letting him have access to his kids not
letting him have access to his kids the
women have all the choice so it's like
if we have all the choice why don't we
have all the responsibility
because there's two people involved in
the creation of a child right but
there's six choices for the woman and
one for the man and the other thing like
the woman can lie where the man can't
the woman can say she's on birth control
say she took the plan B say she has an
IUD and the man could be sleeping with
someone and not even know that where the
woman knows if he's wearing a condom or
not wearing a condom so there's only one
situation like the woman is the only one
that's in a situation where she can
fully consent to everything assuming
there's no grape whatever because she
knows all the details where the man does
it yeah I mean also there's there's
several instances and of a man removing
a condoms during sex a woman noticing in
a man ejaculating in a woman
I don't believe that
I feel like that's like a cop-out to be
honest okay I feel like the girls just
say that I don't really believe it you
didn't notice okay
so what I'm curious about is what
happens when you say all this to a bunch
of random people that you've brought in
off the street
they're like super understanding
[Laughter]
yeah I don't see that yeah I don't see
that no those Americans don't get it I
got it I got I got whale attacked for
one of these opinions because this girl
I was doing Street interviews and this
girl was like
I can't walk home alone in life night my
life is so hard and I was just like she
was she was a whale you know what I mean
she was overweight very fast yeah yeah
and so what she did was she was like
um and I was like well why don't you
just not live in a big city why don't
you just live somewhere safer why don't
you just not walk home alone at night in
a big city
men are more likely to be victims of a
violent crime and then she's like well
and then she attacks me she she tries to
she's like I'll have you you slag I
didn't know what a slag meant okay I
didn't even know what a slag was but she
was like I'll have you you slag I'll
have you and I was like have me like
what
and and so then then she like knocks the
mic out of my hand my friend had to like
pull her away
and then I got it taken off of my
YouTube for privacy [__] you attacked
me and she wouldn't leave my yeah sorry
so yeah they're really understanding
yeah that's so uh I I'm kind of lost for
words a little bit because uh yeah she
was like super nice I love Britain yeah
yeah you see you see some of those goes
uh up and down High Street so on a
Saturday night yeah I mean some it just
depends on the girl like some girls
other girls say they've changed their
entire opinion I've had some girls um
say they never thought of it that way
have you always had these opinions or
has your view of this evolved over time
I've always been more conservative
um some things
I recently decided that women shouldn't
vote
decided women shouldn't involve yeah
that's a new opinion why is that okay
I'll take one for the team yeah okay why
shouldn't women vote because
um we're chemically different every
single day
right yeah and I just and like okay we
make sense hold on does that mean you
shouldn't be on YouTube then because
you're chemically different your
opinions could be [__] because they
could be yeah
should I be banned off of YouTube
because I wanted that to do with voting
it's like a false equivalency okay so to
me it's like okay I feel like if [__]
goes south who's going to war
okay
let me yeah let me let me start from the
beginning let me start actually I wanna
I wanna start from I don't want to be
jumping on this [__] train I want to
start with how I got this opinion okay I
want to start let me let me okay because
I I heard from a guy named Rollo tomasi
genius right very very smart he's a
pickup artist isn't he no no do you know
no no no no no I don't know anything
about it what is it so um
face of YouTube I meant like he's just
like one of the thought leaders I would
say Okay
um but he's not a pickup artist no no no
no okay is he the Italian comedian who's
in his 70s and talks about no no he's
not no he's not no no okay sorry go
ahead we keep interrupting it
I feel like when I when I say this
crazy it does a little bit yeah and when
I when I first heard it thought it was
crazy
but what I heard was that women didn't
want to vote
so when I was like what do you mean
women didn't want to vote like the first
one they threw themselves under [__]
carriages some dead yeah right but was
that women at large no no it wasn't the
majority of women back then we always
talk about the suffragettes but there
was also the anti-suffragettes yeah and
that was the majority of women when
asked if they wanted to vote said no in
the U.S I don't know what it was like
here okay you know this is U.S and I was
like why did women not want to vote
now so I read some of their their
writings from back then okay and they
basically said this is the beginning of
the breakdown of the family because back
then when you got married you became one
and you trusted your husband to make
that decision okay now that was one
argument and I was like okay well but
society's a little different today
argument number two back then they had
to be drafted
so any woman
that wanted to vote
had to go to war because you're voting
in the U.S anyway for your
commander-in-chief because
if they go to war who's gonna have to
deal with the consequence and that's
where we're at is because
if [__] goes south when we go to war the
men are the one that are going to have
to deal with the consequences so yeah I
felt like if we want to vote we should
be equally because women want equality
equally drafted just like the men
and now you're thinking we don't have
the draft anymore right that's probably
your thought
however however we have selective
service in the U.S meaning that if a man
if there's a crisis right and we do go
to war the men have to be like like they
then can be taken to I'm butchering it a
little bit does that make sense but
and if they don't do this they're fined
a hundred thousand dollars
is that equal is that fair where we have
the same rights but we don't have the
same responsibilities if [__] goes south
I don't think that's fair so I thought
about it would I want to be in selective
service if I had to pick
my answer is no no I will give up the
right to vote to not have to do that and
I think that would be fair I think
feminists they want equality but they
don't want the responsibility that comes
with it that's my opinion
okay
now what's interesting about that is in
some countries like Israel it's men and
women through national service yeah I
don't want that so you keep me out of
that keep me
but also women are far more likely to
vote for peaceful and left-leaning party
women are more likely to rage War fun
fact the last 500 years between um night
in the last 500 years
queens were more likely to wage war than
Kings also dispute the idea that
left-wing parties are more peaceful but
yeah so you think and so you genuinely
believe that women shouldn't be allowed
to vote well okay I'm gonna caveat this
okay I don't think it's likely this will
ever happen yeah I've never really gonna
campaign for this to have like how could
nowadays however I think the outcomes
would be better
okay and now this goes back into the
documentary that I'm making so I'm
making a documentary on the court system
here in the UK I wish I brought my
notebook because
I have it all laid out in my neck I
should have brought my notebook I didn't
but um the issue in the UK is that
men only get custody of their kids 10 of
the time
would you agree that's crazy
yes would you agree if it's if your kid
you should get 50 50 custody it depends
off the bat it depends well I actually
don't agree okay go ahead and I'll tell
you why I don't agree with it and this
will make me very problematic because
I'm suggesting that men and women are
different but as someone who has a a
young child
they're way better off with their mother
on average under the age of eight over
the age of eight the kids have better
outcomes with the father single single
father homes have significantly better
outcomes than signals under the age of
eight though they need the mother true
but it's all case specific because if
the mother is a psycho then no and if
the father is abusive then no right or
has addiction issues or whatever else I
personally think that it's 50 50 it's 50
his DNA he should off the bat be
entitled to 50 50 custody now they could
talk about it based on his work schedule
and then switch it you know but off the
bat 50 50 custody would you agree that
ten percent of the time men getting
access to their children being the
primary custody hold like that's that's
insane there's a lot of problems with
the the way that divorce is handle Etc I
mean I know people who uh someone who
was married for a couple of years
they were both professional people
working uh her career and income were
not in any way affected
and then they divorced after a couple of
years and she got a [__] ton of his
money for no [__] reason yeah I'll
tell you about this guy that I
interviewed yesterday and it's going to
tie into the voting thing but it's just
going to take a second so he has three
daughters okay three and he was married
to a good girl for 10 years
um she was like of a Muslim background
so they had like the same does that make
sense yeah
um he
um
the the marriage ended right and all of
a sudden there was a restraining order
put out against him and an allegation of
abuse
why was there allegations of abuse
because in the UK you get free lawyers
if you claim that the man abused you so
now he has to pay for a house that's not
his
okay so he has to because the house is
in his name and he's kicked out of the
house because of the restraining order
he doesn't have access to his kids and
on top of that he has to pay child
support every month he loses his job
because he's so I mean he just lost he's
homeless now loses his job he doesn't
have access to his kids because he's
working in um like electricity or
something and it's like a very high
stress job and like you can't have a guy
that's yeah that yeah he's not focused
yeah yeah yeah so he now he loses his
job now his option is he goes to the
lawyers right and the lawyers
um he has two choices he can either
accept the restraining order and
acceptance it plead guilty basically to
abuse or he can pay 20 to 30 000 pounds
and fight for his kids and the odds he
gets his kids is 10 and this time the
mom is no longer letting him see the
kids they're a mile away from him three
daughters he hasn't seen them in a year
and a half
so what happens next
um he tries to fight now now he's broke
and he goes to court and the problem is
these girls go to women's shelters and
at the women's shelters they have they
basically know the system of how to get
the most money and the most time with
the kids right
and the other issue with the lawyers is
that because they get free counsel from
the women's shelter what incentive do
they have to really help the guy I mean
their number one clients are women
so a lot of these men are given bad
advice in court
so now it takes him a year and a half to
even be able to fight the restraining
order to even get a chance to get access
to his children
like he he and remember just one phone
call you can't go home you don't have
your kids
so then
um
he tries to fight it
um now he's still in court over the
whole thing right but this is where a
lot of men commit suicide
um I certainly would think about it if I
was in that situation where they took
out and he's in his 40s and 50s it's not
like he's a young guy I mean how old are
you guys 40 40. so you can imagine
everything being like your business
being taken your house being taken your
kids being taken tomorrow
now the question is why is this legal
for her to do this there's no
repercussion like isn't that a fair
question yeah yep
um like why why is it legal for her to
deny access to the kids with no legal
repercussion oh oh actually let me get
through it so let's say let's say he
gets his kids let's say he gets to court
he fights it he wins and he gets if he
doesn't get primary custody which he
only could get 10 of the time so most
likely he loses spends all this money in
all this debt still paying for his old
house
she he could get his kids six days a
month finally the Court gives him his
kids
she can just do it all over again
she can she can just file another
restraining order it takes him a year
and a half the other issue it takes what
what happens to two years without seeing
your kids it's a different child you
don't know what she's been telling the
kid they might not even want to see you
after two years
why why is this legal like why why and
that's my question like why on Earth is
this legal like this is an atrocity this
is I started asking my Uber drivers
there are so many Uber drivers that I've
had that talked about how they're
ubering because their ex-wife screwed
them over in divorce so why why is this
happening Family Court okay it's not
based on if you're guilty or if you're
innocent it's based on a balance of
probabilities so you can accuse someone
of something with no evidence and no
repercussions and again the women's
group comes in with all their lawyers
the man comes in broke he comes in with
nothing half the time he can't even
defend himself and if he does again
twenty to thirty thousand dollars the
lawyers do not have as best interest at
heart
now he let's say he he gets lucky right
he wins he gets the kids for six days a
month what happens
she can do it over again and it's legal
because the politicians Pander to women
because the biggest swing voting group
is women
and one incentive do the men have do the
politicians have to change the laws when
they're not going to be reelected
and that's happening right in front of
our eyes and what do you think should
should happen instead it should be 50 50
custody off the bat
um I think they should not have free
counsel just like for a b because it you
it went up 200 allegations of abuse went
up 200 in 2013 when they switched that
law in the UK
um so I think that it should be 50 50
custody off the bat and I don't
um in terms of restraining orders I
don't think it should be that easy to
just get a restraining order against a
guy
um but the problem is in the courts too
is that it's it's based on you only have
to convince one judge and we're in a
society where if a woman cries and is
saying oh he abused me he did this we
just automatically believe them
I mean when's the last time a girl said
to you or anyone in a room that they
were grape they were assaulted there or
anything and anyone really asked
questions and I didn't when I first
started the show I just openly believed
women but then you start asking
questions and [__] doesn't add up
and a lot of times at these women's
shelters they're instructing the women
with what to say to get the most money
out of the men and oftentimes that's
accusing them of abuse so you know you
know the idea that like there are
repercussions for women voting and a lot
of times it's at the expense of men
because all of the politicians are
catering to the women because they are
the biggest swing voting group
wouldn't the no I mean there's a lot of
counter arguments to what you're saying
but wouldn't one of them be that
uh we we lived in a society in which
because men were the ones that had the
vote and by the way actually men mostly
didn't have the vote for quite a long
time as well it was just rich people
rich men but I would be okay with that
too yeah I can tell yeah yeah but but I
just feel like why do you get it like
why do you get a say in something you're
not paying into men pay into it way more
than women do
I mean what women now earn more
particularly young women than young men
yeah but on average across Society men
pay way more tax over the particular
over the course of a lifetime partly
it's because women take time to have
children and I mean that that's also
another argument there like you can't
just measure your contribution to
society by the amount of tax you pay
bringing up the next generation is a
hugely valuable thing that women do
they're not paid for it necessarily
right shouldn't matter but shouldn't
those women do that with their husbands
oh how do you mean like like why do we
want to be in like you should have the
same opinions you should be voting for
the same person as your husband why
why he's got a a lefty girlfriend who
who annoys everyone she doesn't know
everyone you know and she's I just think
it's better for the family unit if
everyone's on the same page like I don't
know you want to be in a house where
you're arguing about politics yes yeah I
want someone who thinks differently to
me that's what we do we argue about
politics all the time not with my wife
by the way but with Francis yeah it's my
work wife yeah
um we think I mean I mean that's fine I
just think like I just prefer more
traditional relationships
so I just prefer relationships where
you're submitting to your husband's
Authority okay but that's great yeah you
know sign me up yeah
there are lots of women who don't want
that shouldn't they be allowed to do
that yeah they can I mean I can't take
away the vote it's here but I actually
will be okay with you know what I've
thought about this too because you know
I'm like are women really not going to
be able to vote I feel like the outcomes
my opinion to be more precise it's
probably that the outcomes would be
better if women didn't vote I'll take
one for the team however
however
I would be okay with the taxpayer thing
but you know where it's like only I
think it's like only net taxpayers can
vote well that's not in this country
would mean half the country doesn't vote
yeah which I'm down
I just feel like okay because if you're
voting okay if I'm getting free stuff
from the government why would I ever
vote against that
I'm just gonna get more
and more free stuff like I just can I
ask you something yeah
there's a combination of things going on
here on the one hand I actually think
some not all but some of the things you
say objectively are not untrue and what
I mean by that is they're true right but
also is there a part of you that's
saying them in the way that you're
saying them because you're being a bit
of a troll
yeah
am I saying them um the way that you're
saying I do say things for comedica fact
that time yeah sure yeah um I don't say
things I don't believe I change my
opinion sometimes
um yeah does that answer your question
no oh no no
no no no no no she said yes as in just
to go along with it but what no it
doesn't answer my question because I
guess what I'm asking you is are you
saying things in a more incendiary
inflammatory way because you know that
gets attention you mean like calling
women whales yes
no I just think it's funny
men can be whales too by the way I know
yeah it's it means something different
but it's right but the men will no okay
I need to say this all right the wheels
accept their outcomes they don't
complain and that's what I'm sick of
what about we also the male oh what
person come on like what you're telling
me there's a whole body positive
movement
oh you're telling me it's the same like
but this is the other thing we have
inside you see he did it it's like
whenever we talk about anything with the
women the automatic reaction but men
yeah but Matt like it's like a pattern
that I noticed and
yeah because the ma the men the men
whales the men whales they accept their
outcomes they know they're not getting
laid they know they're not doing the
women they whine they whine just like
I'm just like stop whining he chose to
be fat
yeah you know there's also a double
standard in terms of obesity in that
like for men it's okay to like I I also
women are more obese than men thank you
in the US anyway I don't know here but
we've not 70 to 80 of women we've
noticed when we were in the US but
um you know I used to take the piss out
of Francis for being overweight and that
was fine he's lost weight he's a bit
miserable now because he doesn't get to
eat the food that he likes but he's
healthy right I don't think if Francis
was female
it would be in any way acceptable for me
to sit here and joke about that and
foreign
when you said I agreed what my I was
saying was yes I see your point but so
for instance with Wales and I'm
approaching this from a comedian's point
of view okay and now I know the language
that I use will elicit a particular
response
and the that words will elicit a
particular response my choice of
language will elicit a particular
response from an audience member
depending on what button I want to push
are you as methodical as that no
um
I just say [__] I think is funny I mean
I true right but funny
um and I think it's funny to call them
whales yeah and when I call them whales
I'm not talking about all right because
this is the other thing well what about
the nice whales okay half the whales
that I call whales they call me ugly
first first and that's what that that
one girl did because this is how I'll
tell you the whale incident started this
is how I started calling women Wheels
because because this woman this woman
the one that attacked me the whale
attack she was like you're I'll have you
you slack she called me a slack first so
I called her a whale back so I was like
you're a whale you're well she started
it I just finished it you know
thank you yeah
did you get on well with women generally
po they love me
small minority I imagine no actually
I've always had like girlfriends so do
you know what I have to say in your
defense not that I'm agreeing with this
I increasingly do see women particularly
on the right like Jessica Vaughan who's
a friend of mine on Twitter she's I
just think the outcomes would be better
like I feel like if we took I'm a
conservative so if we took out the way
it would just be it would go my way more
yeah they would go and what is your way
what does that mean I'm more
conservative okay but what does that
mean
I'm in the U.S Republicans winning okay
I mean that is factually correct but
yeah I'm like personally so me I'm like
I think the outcomes would be better for
America if it was more Republican so
I'll take one for the team guys I'll do
it for you I'll do it for you and what
does that mean the outcomes the outcomes
um
well
one thing I would like to see as the
laws change in terms of child custody I
think it should be 50 50 or maybe even
take the government out of it um I mean
I'm not like a die-hard politics person
to be honest so I'm pro-life so I think
that would be a better outcome for me
pro-gun
um
I don't believe in I don't want to pay a
lot of taxes so take out take out the
taxes take out the government benefits
so basically what you're saying is women
vote left because you're on the right
you'd like women not to be able to vote
I think the outcomes would be better
about for me yeah but and also like
women are just more swayed by like media
so we make 70 to 80 percent of consumer
buying decisions yes so I just feel like
women like we're just not as logical
We're Men they go off of like like women
we vote based on how we feel where men
will look at like the pros and the cons
of something
so she's making good movies yeah it's
like it's like okay we don't even know
we don't even know what we want for
dinner okay we don't even know what we
want for dinner do you think we should
pick the leader of the Free World and
they'll be like well not all women okay
I think I know more successful women
than most just being in the line of work
I I know a lot of women that have done
well I played I I had a pro volleyball
contract offered I know a lot of women
in sports that played at the highest
level that have achieved a lot of things
at the end of the day we're all still
women
so I'll take one for the team guys yeah
okay that's interesting so that being
the case we can all agree that America
is rightly and more right-leaning than
the UK yeah yeah so I'm not a die-hard
politics person but yeah but no but we I
think that's that's a pretty standard
yeah Viewpoint so so why the UK then
Paul as opposed to America oh I'll tell
you why so I didn't mean to end up here
yeah I didn't mean to it was like an
accident so so I before YouTube was
playing Semi-Pro or I was playing no
sorry I need to start over so when I got
out of college I was selling copiers and
I decided that I wanted to play
volleyball overseas I was going to try
to get a pro contract and I was
recruited to play volleyball here
so
um
I
it was a year program to get my masters
and at the end of the year you
hypothetically get a pro contract which
I did with the YouTube stuff like so
yeah so I kind of like I started the
show when I got here and I didn't expect
it to like get huge you know what I mean
yep so then I kind of just got like
stuck here because I was like I have to
move my producer and it was just I mean
you know how it is if you guys wanted to
move this whole operation what a
headache it would be yeah yeah so yeah
yeah like imagine so I'd have to I'm
like the voltage converters
so I kind of accidentally ended up here
but I am gonna leave eventually yeah
yeah I can see why I've done like your
opinions are that widely shared in this
country yeah no they love me here
listen there's something else uh uh I
think it's by you know we sure we call
the show trigonometry yeah but even by
our standards this has been pretty
triggering for a lot of people however
there's something even more tricking
that I do have to ask you about because
in between the time that we booked you
to come on the show and you actually
coming on the show you had a guy called
Nick Fuentes yeah yeah Nick yeah uh and
then you did an interview with this guy
like this is not a guy we would ever
have on because he's a racist uh
Holocaust denying piece of [__] as far
as I'm concerned but you had them on and
then you took that interview down
unapologized so what happened with the
whole thing oh there is there's a I
can't talk too much there's like legal
things going on legal things going on
yeah there's um not not with Nick but
just yeah but there's
um
I I have a video coming out about that
whole thing so you guys have to wait for
the video
well but I will say I
um I did not find Nick to be racist um
my staff actually did not find him to be
racist wait he was talking to an Italian
girl next to you and saying that she
shouldn't have a black boyfriend or
something along those lines he he
doesn't believe in see I don't really
want to go
with race mixing
things they just said he wasn't being
racist and I watched him be racist on
your show well I mean it to me he says
the same things that like like there's a
lot of people that think like that when
it doesn't make it less racist just
because other people think it you could
say that but to me it's like I put it
his argument is more about culture it's
easier if you date someone in your
culture
um she
to you'd have to watch the full thing
but was like being a bit like combative
to him and to me he was just like
kidding but yeah you did say I am a bit
racist even enough and in fact in your
apology you said that he said racist
things
um well there's a video coming out about
all of that but you'll see it's coming
out okay well the reason I'm asking you
is because it's kind of like a big deal
that you had this guy on do you see what
I'm saying he he is incredibly toxic
um I like I'm just telling you my
personal experience with him um we
filmed hours and hours and hours of
footage with him there was that one in
like to me if you watch the full clip it
puts it in a little bit of context yeah
but he was really polite he showed up on
time like we just he also and honestly
he did a panel and he spoke about his
opinions on Race mixing and a lot of
people agreed with him
okay but that doesn't change whether
it's racist or not right but what I'm
getting do you think it's racist to like
because I'm curious yeah you think it's
racist like if I'm Irish and I say I
want to date someone that's Irish do you
think that's racist no but if I say to
you you're Irish therefore you shouldn't
date a black man that is racist yeah
if you're Irish and because when he
spoke about it on the show it was more
about culture than race but but to me
that doesn't really work as an argument
post so I'll give you an example I'm
half Latin American I take off the my
dad's Irish side
if I date a Jamaican woman a Jamaica and
Venezuela have a very similar culture
we're culturally very similar we have
the same food the same religion whatever
else so to me that argument doesn't work
do you see what I'm saying wait
Venezuela and what and Jamaica so
Venezuela's at the top of South America
and Jamaica is all Trinidad which is
literally you see it over the water yeah
well it's just when he was talking he
was talking about how he wanted to date
an Italian woman
like versus
um
like he even said he wouldn't want to
date a British girl he'd want to date an
Italian woman so I was like how is he a
white supremacist no he's allowed to
date who he wants yeah him telling your
Italian friend she shouldn't be dating a
black man that's right the racist part
don't you think
um I'd have to remember what he said in
the clip but maybe yeah maybe okay yeah
so that's why I'm asking you because you
you do have controversial guests as we
do and there's nothing wrong with
talking to people who are controversial
but Nick Fuentes is a very different
kettle of fish as we say here right yeah
um my my opinion is that he was polite
overall um he was a good guest he was
also denying the Holocaust from whatever
okay I'm not with that
keep me out of that one I'm not with the
race like that's not my thing but I just
think people are allowed to have their
opinion so if he has crazy opinions let
him have his opinions and I think he he
should be allowed to talk about it on a
podcast but isn't it also the duty Poe
of the person interviewing them to push
back on those opinions when they come up
and actually challenge him and
investigate them and to
it basically push back on it yeah I mean
we could do another show where we push
back more it's not the end all be-all
but surely that isn't that there is
isn't that I wanted to do like one with
Dr Umar but he didn't want to come sad
Dr
Umar has like the same opinions as Nick
like he doesn't believe in race mixing
too he's just black yeah it's like a
common yeah yeah there are some people
who believe that sure yeah but you know
when you were talking about the
Holocaust with him he was saying it's
like slavery it got embellished and you
were sort of going I kind of I can see
your point and that's why I found a bit
confusing because then in your apology
you said well I wasn't really educated
on these things yeah um yeah you're kind
of taking that back again
um there's a statement coming out on
everything so you guys just have to wait
for it yeah like well I just yeah from
our perspective we're kind of saying to
you what we thought you might have said
to him which is if a guest says or does
something controversial you kind of want
to ask and find out why they've done and
we have to make you by the way I if this
is coming across as confrontational it's
not the intention at all because
whenever I see a guest not be challenged
enough on someone's show I often think
they're but by the grace of God go I
because we've had people on the show
who've said controversial things and
I've sort of missed the moment and I
kind of didn't challenge them enough and
I felt bad about it afterwards yeah I
don't know if you remember because
you're not a political person you might
not there was a guy called Darren Grimes
who had a guy called Dr David starkion
and he said something about how of
course slavery wasn't genocide otherwise
there wouldn't be so many damn blacks
in the west right and that got picked up
by all the media and they all had to go
him and I just saw a fairly young
inexperienced interviewer and Darren
failed to challenge someone who he
looked up to and respected on what was
just a bad phrasing more than anything
right
so I I'm I totally understand why you
may have missed something or not have
not have jumped in on something that you
maybe felt that you should have jumped
in on but that but the reason that
Francis and I would never have Nick
Fuentes on is precisely because he says
all that [__] all the time so if you
were to actually challenge him on some
of his apparent views you'd spend the
entire three hours doing it did you
watch the full video I watched some of
it not before video yeah okay I I did
challenge him at points of it okay tell
us about it tell us I mean we had a
whole panel on Race mixing yeah and like
we had like that was why he came out
like the political stuff was just
because he was there like so I did a
one-on-one as like uh the reason I
brought him on was I saw him on no
jumper like talking about
um race mixing and I've heard that point
of view um but it's usually like not
people look different that have that
point of view usually
um
so like I like I've heard it but I've
just never heard it like like that I
guess so we just brought him on a panel
just like about race mixing and they did
a whole panel on it but then he was
denying the Holocaust you know that was
crazy yeah I thought it was but that's
what he does that's why I'm asking you
well yeah but we brought him on to talk
about race mixing that's what we brought
him on because it's a relationship show
and then we just interviewed him because
he was there but there will be people po
who will say well if you're gonna bring
that person on and look again this isn't
to you know misrepresent or do any of
those types of things the reason we have
this show is so we can talk and have
honest conversations because part of
this is for me to clarify my thinking
about different issues that's why we do
the shot
but part of it is also when you bring
someone on you can't also ignore that
element of it do you see what I mean I
just don't know what you mean by ignore
no because if you're not addressing the
fact that he's a holocaust denier then
well I mean I don't see what I mean I
mean I don't agree that the Holocaust
didn't happen like
um yeah I mean I I was just listening to
him yeah and I think you're allowed to
listen to people that you might not
agree with and I think as women we're
more agreeable than men so a lot of
times you might take it as me agreeing
um but no I didn't well you did say so
it's kind of like slavery it's been
embellished I was talking about how
people use atrocities to control people
and I was quoting Thomas Sowell who's a
black author I'm a big fan of Thomas
yeah so I was quoting Thomas Sowell and
speaking about his ideas of people watch
the full interview yeah
um and I said that in the interview yeah
when I was talking about how people use
an atrocity to control people
yeah so but you don't think that's what
happened with the Holocaust
um it sounded like it based on what he
was saying but he's a well-known
Holocaust tonight
that's where I was feeling sorry sorry
at the time that's what I was talking
about it sounded like some of Thomas
sowell's ideas
um but do I think that the Holocaust
didn't happen no that's crazy yeah
um go ahead so
I guess what is what do you think your
responsibility is when you bring on
controversial guests onto the show do
you have any responsibility what what do
you believe
further gas no not for the guests for
the content that you put out Pearl yeah
I'm responsible for all the content I
put out
you're responsible for all the content
that you put out and you now look at
that and think you shouldn't have done
that you made a mistake you made an
error I don't regret having someone
controversial on if I had to do it again
I would have maybe had someone on the
opposite end of the argument that could
push back
um but how I probably would have did it
if I had to do it again one full
interview with both of them let them
talk let them say what they're gonna say
and then bring them together
so who would you have on the other sense
so you'd have Dr Uma Umar stupid
to be black that's not that that that is
that's playing do you see that kind of
identity yeah but then we did a whole
panel with people that disagreed with
him so we did do that
all right yeah well I I well I'm a bit
confused about is
you did a whole apology but it sounds
like you're not asking me about this
kind of matters I have a statement
coming out about it so yeah okay okay
all right well we'll leave it to your
statement uh listen we always wrap up
the show with the same question we ask
all our guests which is what's the one
thing you think we're not talking about
that we really should be
um
men's issues yeah that's my yeah yeah do
you want to elaborate or have it to
leave it there
um no I would just say like men I just
think men not getting custody of their
kids I think that is an issue that
nobody talks about okay sweet well Pearl
uh thank you very much why can people
find uh you online uh just pearly things
so you can look up just pearly things on
YouTube all right well thanks for coming
on the show and thank you guys for
watching and listening we'll see you
very soon with another brilliant
interview like this one I probably won't
be quite like this one uh or so uh take
care and see you soon and for those of
you who like your trigonometry on the go
it's always available as a podcast take
care and see you soon guys
what it did and do you think of Andrew
take considering he featured highly in
your podcast
[Music]